介绍一下，
我今年30周岁，
我跟你一样，
也是从一个小地方，
然后现在我在一个新一线城市在生活，
然后我是自己做了一个很喜欢的一个职业，
虽然我不是播音的专业出身的，
但是我现在做了一个职业是商业的主持人，
然后现在的话，
通过几年的努力，
我没有想到自己能够说，
哎，
我真的能够坚持到自己喜欢的职业，
而且还坚持了这么久，
现在还做的挺不错的啊，
收入也还可以，
我是天生感觉自己更适合舞台的，
但虽然说坚持这个路挺不容易，
所以我能够坚持下来，
也是打破了很多的困难吧，
然后坚持到现在，
今年是未婚未育，
没有生娃，
然后也没有说很着急想要结婚，
我觉得一切都挺好的，
去年的时候刚好刷到直播间，
刷到你的视频，
我感觉这个姐姐好亲切，
而且嗯，
你也是代表了很多，
可以说是底层女性的一个崛起的，
或者是一个非常优秀的代表吧，
我就觉得你是我的榜样，
所以我就觉得，
哎，
我30岁啊，
生日的话，
我想做一个特别的事情，
就是跟你连个麦，
跟你。
聊个天，
然后分享一下我的来时路，
我我刚才听到你说你大学的时候一个月300，
我跟你说我当时我要上大学，
是全家人都反对的，
但是我当时呃，
我就很坚持，
就是那种死掉读书的那种，
然后我是找了一个我妈妈的一个朋友借的钱，
然后我就把这个书给坚持下来了，
后面都是我自己出来了以后自己还钱的，
然后当时的话，
我是13年上的大学，
我当时一个月一开始生活费就有600呢，
我也是跟你们一样吧，
就是没钱了就自己去努力，
我当时也就是，
呃，
因为会唱歌，
会主持，
我就也是靠这种嗯表演，
然后去赚点那种生活费，
我很多我的第一台手机都是自己给自己买的，
我且也也是那么一步步走来的，
那我的经历跟你也买像的，
然后我听了很多直播间的一些朋友，
一些女性，
她们在不同的城市，
然后有不同的遭遇，
我觉得只要自己能够，
嗯，
勇敢，
然后做自己认认为正确的事情，
不要被朋友的怀疑所质疑自己，
然后一定要坚持。
自己我觉得自己的路一定会越来越好的，
就像龙飞姐姐一样，
嗯，
谢谢你哦，
谢谢你来跟我分享你自己的这个成长的心路历程，
其实你身上有一股劲儿是我特别喜欢的，
就是当你呃认准了自己要读大学，
哪怕家里面人反对，
你愿意去跟你的妈妈的朋友借钱，
你也要做这个决定，
其实我觉得这点真的是那你的自己的性格决定了你今天工作也很顺心，
找到了自己喜欢的职业，
其实有很很多千千万万的女孩子，
可能她的命运就是呃，
爸妈说怎么样就怎么样了啊，
她很难去反抗自己的这个命运，
这一点的话，
其实真的值得为你点赞，
这一点真的是从你身上也看到了我自己以前小时候的就是经历，
我也有过那样的经历，
就是想读高中，
爸爸妈妈更倾向于读师专的时候，
我也是义无反顾的坚持了自己挺好的，
看到你现在，
你现在这个工作你自己喜欢，
而且收入也不错，
嗯，
这个就是就是你自己争取来的，
我是大姐姐，
我下面还有弟弟妹妹，
就是很普通的，
很大众很平繁的那种所谓的这种领导重男轻女的家庭吧。
啊，
我发现我最近两次回家都挺不开心的，
说不出来是因为什。
不是，
但是那种环境还有情绪，
就就是会让我突然又回到了那种小时候那种感觉，
嗯，
所以我觉得很多姐姐，
如果说大家都有这种家庭的经历的话呢，
我也特别支持大家，
就是应该逃离那种生活，
还有逃那种家庭的氛围，
因为一旦进入到那种愤怒，
我发现哪怕我已经在外面很多年了，
我还是会一下子陷入到以前那种不开心的情绪，
我也挺喜欢你说的那个王慧玲姐姐的，
我觉得人生就3万多天，
我希望我们直播间的那么多的。
女性都能够开开心心的，
嗯，
度过这一生吧，
有没有什么问题要跟王菲姐去聊一聊呢？
问题的话，
其实。
我在想我30以后的一个生活，
关于生育，
嗯，
或者是，
或者是结婚了，
有异性的这个朋友在追求你吗？
在想要跟你，
呃，
发展关系吗？
有，
但是比较少，
我觉得我们这个职业不太好，
不太好就是交友，
你现在这个职业是完全独立的一个主持人职业，
还是说也挂靠了一个公司，
类似于经纪公司的这样一个情况呢？
你没有挂靠，
完全独立的状态，
你的客户资源是通过什么途径来的呢？
客户资源是通过我们都有很多的通道群，
然后也做了好几年了，
也会有一些朋友互相介绍，
大概就是这样，
然后但是我们有个行规，
就是哎，
我们去到了现场都能够私加人家的客户，
所以很多人以为我们会认识很多朋友，
但其实并没有，
因为我们要要在这一行要能走的长远，
别人也会，
你会不会就是撬别人的客户呀，
这样啊，
那你主要做的这个主持人是哪方面的，
是属于商业，
比如说候开业还是属于婚庆，
就是侧重于哪方面的主持呢？
都有，
哎，
嗯，
婚期会接的比较少一点，
因为我着重的这个点不在这，
接的多一点是商业，
你自己有没有做自媒体呢？
今天既然你来了，
我们可以就跟你聊聊商业的这样的事情啊，
我们人的时间是有限的，
就是说我们一天的时间是有限的，
我们想要挣更多的钱，
要么就是啊，
一天的时间能重复卖，
比如说龙可以姐，
我录一个课程，
我这个课程可以重复的卖，
就相当于我把一天的时间反复的无数次的去变现，
或者说我写一本书，
我把一天的时间也可以反复的无数次的去变现，
对吧，
要么就是提高你的单价，
就是你这一天的价格，
可能有的时候800，
可能有的著名一点的可能就是8000，
那怎么才能实现800~8000的这个跨越呢？
就是你有足够多的客户资源，
你有挑选的资本，
对不对，
光靠别人介绍，
光靠这些东西你是很难有足够的客户资源的，
你必须要把自媒体这个东西做起来，
而且自媒体一定是每次发都是你很专业的去主持的那个剪影，
主持的那个片段，
你要学一下，
比如说嗯，
怎么剪辑，
怎么配乐，
怎么拍，
自己才能够显示出你的既专业又优雅又上档次，
对吧，
让人你看了之后，
比如说要有一个开业要。
这种重要的会议愿意请像你这样的形象和气质的主持人去，
对吧？
对，
其实踏入了30，
我觉得我重点考虑的也是我的一个职业，
因为自由职业不知道未来的去路是哪里，
然后自由职业一定要有自己能够获取源源不断客户资源的能力，
如果说完全靠那种别人同同行给我介绍，
或者直接给我介绍这个东西，
然后去了时候又不能加其他的客户资源的话，
那这个东西是我，
我认为是很难把你的时间的单价卖出更好的价格的，
明白了，
嗯，
谢谢，
谢谢龙飞姐姐，
嗯，
好的，
那我没什么问题，
我们啊，
好，
拜拜，
我看到评论区有很多姐妹不愿意听啊，
成长的故事啊，
但你认真想一想，
就像刚才龙飞姐跟这位姐妹聊的这个故事，
对大家有没有启发呢？
我认为他是有启发的，
就比如说他自己很有主见，
能够在自己想读大学跟家里人不同意的情况下，
他可以去借他妈妈的朋友的钱去支撑自己把这个大学读出来，
请问这样的勇气值不值得大家学习？
我直播间有很多女孩子一直都是活在父母的安排里，
一直都是活在对吧，
被别人推着走，
从来没有。
自己掌握过方向盘，
从来没有自己掌握过船的船舵，
我觉得这这个勇气是值得我们所有人学习的，
再包包括刚才龙飞姐讲的那个商业变现的这个问题，
值不值得大家去思考一下，
因为我们人的时间，
老天爷对于我们的时间这件事情上是相对来说公平的，
都给了我们大概3万多天的时间，
你怎么把这3万多天的时间，
嗯，
用俗一点的说法变成更多的钱，
让自己更有对吧，
更有这种价值感，
或者说更有这个安全感，
要么就是你同一段时间能反复卖，
就像我菲姐刚刚说到的，
我写书也好，
我讲课也好，
相当于我砸一段时间就进去，
之后的话，
我这个东西可以反复的去卖，
不断的去变现，
要么就是把我单，
呃，
单位的这个时间，
一小时的时间卖出更高的价格，
那怎么才有更高的价格呢？
这个是市场供需决定的。
市场的供需就是需要你的人越多，
你的价格就越高，
那怎么才能实现需要我的人越多呢？
我必须要让足够多的人认识我，
了解我，
了解我的专业能力，
看到我身上的才华，
看到我身上能给他带来的这种添砖加瓦，
给他的公司带来的这种形象上，
气质上，
对吧？
呃，
气场上的这种天分，
我才有可能得到更多的客户资源，
才有可能把我的这个一小时的单价卖出更高的价格。
所以我刚刚跟姐妹聊的这个，
他一定要做自媒体，
而且自媒体要全面开发，
不光是要做抖音，
现在你能想象得到的所有的能够展示自己的自媒体都去做，
你不知道对吧，
哪块云彩下雨在哪个自媒体你就做起来了。
而且做自媒体的时候，
不要单纯展示自己的美貌，
不要单纯展示是自己的什么穿衣打扮，
一定是展示自己的专业能力，
一定是把你我跟你讲，
我们姐以前我讲课的时候，
我有一个很重要的习惯，
我每一场讲课我一定要给自己录音，
如果有条件的话，
我一定要给自己录像，
完了之后我可以就像刚才那个姐妹，
她每一场主持一定要给自己录像，
一定要问摄像的小哥要到那个录像的原片，
然后你回去一定要学剪辑剪那种，
你看有很多那种主持人啊，
就是一摘麦一走出来放点慢动作。
风一吹过来，
头发一飘起来，
那超有气质，
老有气质了，
然后在舞台上对不对，
然后你讲几句话，
能把一个镜头能够看到线下的那个人在专注的看着你，
很崇拜的看着你，
哦，
那一瞬间老有气质了，
这个人的价值感就上来了，
一定要去学，
学各种各样的，
就是人家那些主持人在台上他怎么剪出这个视频，
才能让你显得很高大上，
显得很专业啊，
你要学这个啊，
这样你才能积累自己的客户，
等有一天你能积累到自己的客户，
你根本就吃不完这些客户的时候，
你就可以养团队了。
对吧，
你就可以养这个助理实习生嘛，
慢慢慢慢就发展起来了，
因为我芬姐也是这么一点一点，
那么成长起来的，
就是想办法得多挣钱啊，
怎么才能多挣钱，
就只要不违法，
不犯罪呃，
不损害别人的利益的时候，
尽可能的要学会包装自己，
要学会展示自己，
全方位的去在众多领域去包装和展示自己的能力才华，
然后有个朋友说龙飞是真心实意的教。
是真的，
我真的是掏心掏肺的交，
掏心掏肺的也不说交吧，
就是分享分享，
我也真的希望我自己的这些，
呃，
女孩子啊，
就是关注龙飞姐的这些女孩子，
早一天成为自己的人生当中的那个，
就是把握方向盘的那个人，
早一天能够掌控自己的命运，
早一天能够呃，
找到一个窍门，
能够挣更多的钱，
那你就早一天获得真正的自由和幸福，
一个人拥有选择权是一件特别幸福的事情。